on va parler d'amour à un corner non
mais c'est vrai est ce que pour toi et
msiska de plus beau dans vos fiches
aussi bien par contre inquiète parce que
je m'étais crise qui minait déjà
réellement tombé amoureux plus de trois
fois dans sa vie toi corneille ce que tu
vas tomber amoureux plus de trois fois
bien bas non non une fois une fois
jusqu'à fin mai c'est quoi ses
beaux-frères cemac et un conduit ces
bateaux on est en bas dans tous les deux
c'est l'explosion non ça c'est toi
maison
[Applaudissements]
sa tronche s'est taillé la prise dans sa
tronche et a fait la une deux fois moz
way aux braves gens c'est moi je connais
toute ta vie n'était pas amoureux du
prof de ski non ma fille tu celui
qu'elle avait connu à montréal inscrits
et bien ça y est c'est le bâton c'est
pour ça qu'ils étaient lamoureux plus de
trois fois dit la vérité ou pas chaque
coeur d'artichaut cm mais problème parce
que du coup quand on est très passionnel
on cassure comme son amoureux on se
lasse aussi très vite ils devraient
comme un enfant qui a un jouet c'est
l'amour c'est une malheureuse dirigeants
étaient communiqués comme me voilà elle
aussi tu as fait quatre fois moins on
est des gens sensibles on est basse et
ça donc je vais faire le break et ça
vient et ça peut aussi arriver là c'est
comme moi ça va ça vient ça part mais
qu'on sasbach de géraldine vous
premières amours amoureux un mari
amoureux et puis le nouvel homme de ma
vie à moi c'est un pyramide ou encore
oasis isabelle une fois où un wiiware
une fois alors une fois en célébrant une
fois sociale y est simplement il faut
que il faut que je connaisse pour un
commentaire
pour amadou sachant que ce sont deux
réels a fonctionné j ai très romantique
avec son partenaire pour lui prouver son
amour et romantique toi qu'en live web
je te sens dernier truc romantique côté
fait ben je fais des fois j'en vois des
fleurs sans raison ah ouais c'est beau
ça non mais c'est sa raison et j'adore
oui alors que moi je l'envoie sur les
roses
merci voilà alors en très bonne voie
mais la raison corner séquences et sans
raison à bien un cadeau sans raison
c'est l'agencé 'dow alors c'est ou alors
comme ouais ouais ouais ouais je vous
dis moi je vais vous dire en mon nom
comme neige non mais c'est vrai alors
attention je donne un petit conseil
ça veut dire conseils pratiques frais ne
fait jamais un trop gros bouquet gros
bruit égale quelque chose à se reprocher
sur petit bouquet je suis sympa ouais
j'ai rien fait je suis persuadé prends
mon portable toi plaisir
c'est à partir de maintenant les petits
bouquets ça commence à être aussi à la
couleur des roses si vous offrez des
roses rouges pour amours blancs manège
on craint alors à toiture tout petits
bouquets petit paquet jaune et c'est
pour les métiers rose
ah ouais c'est pour l'amitié est
compliquée et rouge c'est vraiment
l'amour passionné
tu vois tu as quand il chante
[Rires]
je pense à tous les pauvres mecs on est
entre la gare des missions qui seront
très soit qu'un énorme bouquet sur les
réseaux non je me dis petit bouquet
petit bouquet rien à se reprocher gros
bouquet je vais vous dire c'est pas bon
moi je sais me suis jamais salie à
jamais leur qui l'enserré qui roulent en
tic et romantique vous jean michel mr
ban avec qui avec votre chien non même
si monsieur j'adore les animaux envoyer
tout le monde
moi j'aimais les petites attentions
j'essaye toujours notre souvenir qu'elle
m'a dit on est passés quelque part l'a
repéré quelque chose ça et après de le
montrer que j'avais pensé j'ai tout
oublié brno si c'est vrai est trop lente
excès de prudence
on a nous est venue mourir ça alors vous
qu'est romantique vous vous réussir le
romantisme s'applique au quotidien
romantique et galles 13 x le mois mais
c'est vrai c'est pas très sympa car que
200 ans
mais on peut tout demander quand même
même si la connais pas et tu m peut-être
qu'on peut faire une rencontre d'une
manière ou d'une autre le romantisme
apporter ouvre des portes
sachez le dragon c'est la perle mais
j'aime les week-ends improvisé à week
end par exemple voilà le matin vous vous
réveillez vous êtes dans la cuisine vous
prenez votre petit déjeuner voilà
personne arrive avec une petite valise
alors attention ne n'ai pas eu des
grosses valises sinon
[Rires]
attention petit voilà petit balise est
possible de gros moyens ça veut dire
c'est pas bon alors oui et donc à
l'arrivée qu'une pas niçois on va où
laisse toi faire non suis moi ah ouais
voilà voilà donc pas qu'on m'appelle
prison au placard dire mais qu'est ce
qui veut dire que je crois que je serais
lui je te sens pas là je suis romantique
ah ouais ouais j'en ai pas l'air comme
ça mais c'est avec toi est aussi petit
bouquet pour qu'on te voit derrière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est que dans le journal sur la tête
de ma mère savait de paris l'a rendu
budget les invités sont bien moqués
d'eux sort qui sera pas le bouquet ou ça
doit de faveur comme un phare à l'avant
et on enlève ces mois vers la wii alors
est ce que tu pourrais arrêter de faire
par amour corneille qu'est ce que je
pourrais arrêter de faire par amour
ouais pratiquement tous vous si vous
m'aimez en tout cas arrêtez monsieur
quoi sert est pratiquement tous
ouais je n'ai pratiquement parce que là
j'ai géré un client en tête mais ouais
carrément away site ce que sa carrière
femmes et aux différentes acariens je
pus que tu chantes maintenant tu restes
à la maison
1 tu vas jouer à call of duty et tu
essaies tout ça dépend de la raison
après ça dépend la prison à la maison
mais c'est si ge
saab est arrêtée mais j'ai ralenti mme
gérard j'ai ralenti ma carrière par un
par amour mais pas juste pour elle mais
pour pour la famille pour les enfants
les apparences et ouais tu veux pas tu
pas de battre sur tous les arrêts
sérieux soit pas moi pardon j'ai ralenti
un jour sur le périph il faut réduire la
vitesse
non et non moi un jour par mange arrêter
le ping pong lever la personne quoi
voulez repris rapidement non non tu
t'emmerdes pas exclu non c'est vrai qu
est ce que vous pourriez arrêté par
amour mais là où kelly a raison c'est
qu'effectivement si elle vous aime et
vous demande pas de vous changer
sera ce que vous êtes apprécié
l'investissement de l'horreur après tu
peux prendre des concessions d'une part
nous mêmes sans que soit demandée tu
vois de mireille dumas là
c'est pour la caisse couple est arrêté
par amour ou raymond l'athénée mahbod
non mais laura rythme
[Rires]
qu'est ce que pour les arrêter c'est
votre mari vous a demandé au salon wii
je conseille pas de me demander trop
souvent non c'est vrai ah ouais ouais
tiens pourquoi pas ce qu'il trouve qu'on
pourrait faire plus de tout ensemble si
je suis là c'est que je le veux la paix
du motard alors ça je vous le conseille
pas non plus ah ouais ce qui n'est pas
diplomate humble adore on peut dire que
tu me manques toujours après autant de
temps c'est beau c'est beau l'amour
moi je sais bien que la fin surtout la
fin si la lada en annonçant et c'est
beau c'est d'amour sa branche voyages
bousiges et j'aime beaucoup alain et ont
une fois de plus on y voit là y voilà
franchement oui
qu'est ce que vous pourriez arrêtez-vous
par aman votre croisière également comme
un sens moi j'ai arrêté durant dix ans
j'ai arrêté de me l'avait demandé
d'ailleurs chez amour de jeunesse alors
j'ai arrêté de regarder la télé toute la
nuit
et maintenant j'ai fini qu'une
oreillette dans dans l'oreille
c'est au cas où c'est la gaillette de ce
qu alors y était cassé je vous le dis
nous dit jamais un salut au mode on leur
y est j'ai bien sûr il a marqué par
amour voa benhaim us et la télé le soir
lui c'est enfin rien vous moi je
pourrais arrêter de fumer
ah ouais which c'est compliqué mais je
pourrais arrêter de fumer par mois en
plus ça serait bien pour toi si tu peux
faire plaisir à ton corps vas-y que vous
pour y arrêter les uv
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dur le mesure censée changer les
habitudes c'est à dire être amoureux
donc changer de vie et je suis tellement
bien dans ma célibat et ma solitude que
j'adore avant ils sont 66 jours pour
créer une nouvelle habitude à son
cerveau bah il faut 66 minutes pour se
montrer jaloux lorsqu'il est amoureux ou
là on était jaloux non je peux même
ouais comme moi mais je me rends
maintenant parce que moi je vais vous
dire j'ai confiance
moi j'ai confiance en mon travail j'ai
confiance en la justice